nearly 12 years after the end of sri
lanka's civil war
the pain is still raw for those whose
sons daughters and husbands disappeared
this was a protest earlier this month
they want answers accountability and
justice
they're not getting any because the
united nations human rights council
says the highest levels of sri lanka's
government is in denial about past
crimes the space for civil society and
independent media
which have grown significantly is now
rapidly shrinking
the independence of the judiciary the
human rights commission of sri lanka
the national police commission and other
key bodies
has been deeply eroded by the recently
adopted
20th constitutional amendment
president gotta buy rajapaksa was
defense secretary at the end of the
civil war his brother mahinda
was president a hundred thousand people
were killed in the 26 year long war
between tamil separatists and the
government both sides are accused of
crimes
including murder and torture
and now the u.n says minority groups are
facing more discrimination
this protest in february was a rare
combined march of muslims and tamils
with a long list of complaints including
trying to get education in the tamil
language
and oppressive police surveillance of
muslims sri lanka's government
rejects all the allegations made in the
report including claims
it uses divisive rhetoric sri lanka's
constitution
guarantees as a mention before
fundamental rights of
all citizens and anyone can
canvas under the fundamental rights
and also sri lanka
in the last few years as well as today
we have all our programs
economic social or other beneficial
programs
all are equally
enjoyed and implemented from the
north to the south lila nadaraj's son
was taken away by the military at the
end of the war
she's no idea what happened to him but
is convinced he's still alive
her story is the same for thousands of
other families
what we see now is that they're trying
to make us fed up and stop the protests
so we can't trust them we will have to
go to the international community to get
our children back
as we have realized that there is no
point going to the government here
the un's high commissioner for human
rights has urged member states
to consider prosecuting alleged crimes
in sri lanka
to try and get answers for the thousands
of people like
leela bernard smith al-jazeera